Вітаю вас друзі!
Мене звуть Юрій
Я викладач математики Креативної
Міжнародної Дитячої Школи
І сьогодні у нас урок
математики в 6-му класі
Основні властивості рівнянь
З 5 класу ви пам’ятаєте, як
розв’язувати рівняння такого виду:
5х – 3 = 17
Спочатку ви розв’язуєте відносно 5х.
5х у вас зменшене.
Для того, щоб знайти невідоме
зменшене, вам потрібно
до різниці додати від’ємник.
Тобто 17 додати 3
Дивимось на дошку.
5х буде дорівнювати 20
Відповідно, 5х = 20 це те саме,
що 5 помножити на х.
Відповідно для того, щоб знайти
х, потрібно 20 розділити на 5.
Дивимось на дошку.
Ви згадали, як розв’язуються
рівняння 5 класу.
Але постає питання: а як розв’язувати
такого виду рівняння? Наприклад
Увага на дошку
Ви бачите, зараз у вас і в
правій, і в лівій частині є невідомі.
Як же розв’язуються такі рівняння?
Для розв’язування таких рівнянь
використовуються
основні властивості рівнянь.
Перейдемо до них.
Отже, перша властивість.
Вона звучить таким чином:
якщо до обох частин рівняння додати
або відняти одне і те ж саме число,
то корінь рівняння не зміниться.
Тобто, буде таким самим,
як і початкового рівняння.
Давайте продемонструємо і
переконаємося, що ця властивість працює.
Згадаємо наше перше рівняння.
Увага на екран.
Я зараз до обох частин додам якесь число.
Наприклад, 8.
Додаю в лівій частинці
8 і в правій частинці 8.
Давайте подивимося, що в нас вийде?
В лівій частині ми можемо
звести, так звані, подібні доданки.
5х у нас залишається.
Мінус 3 додати 8 буде плюс 5, буде +5.
В правій частинці 17 плюс 8, буде 25.
Давайте розв’яжемо дане рівняння.
Дивимось на дошку.
Знову ж таки, розв’язуємо відносно 5х.
Тому, щоб знайти невідомий доданок,
нам потрібно від суми, тобто 25,
відняти відомий доданок, тобто 5.
Дивимось на дошку.
Записуємо результат:
5х буде дорівнювати 20
Для того, щоб знайти зараз х,
нам потрібно 20 поділить на 5.
Х буде дорівнювати 4
Як бачите, корінь не змінився.
Отже, властивість працює.
Так само вона працює і для віднімання.
Можете впевнитися в цьому самостійно.
Спробуйте відняти якесь
число від цього рівняння.
І побачите, що корінь
рівняння не зміниться.
Розглянемо деякий нюанс.
Подивіться, будь ласка, уважно на дошку.
Я знову таки повертаюсь
до нашого рівняння:
5х – 3 = 17 Дивимось на дошку.
Я зараз до обох частин знову
додам одне й те саме число,
але воно буде дорівнювати 3.
Додати 3 і додати 3
Давайте подивимось, що у нас вийде?
В лівій частині 5х – 3 + 3
– 3 + 3 = 0
Тому в лівій частині залишиться просто 5х.
В правій частині я поки
що так і залишу 17 + 3
Що це буде означати?
Це буде означати, що я переніс
доданок -3 в праву частину
і змінив його знак на протилежний.
Тобто в мене є наслідок
з цієї властивості.
Запам’ятайте:
з кожної частини в іншу
можна перенести доданок,
при цьому потрібно змінити
його знак на протилежний.
Зараз початкове рівняння
у мене виглядало 5х – 3.
Мінус трійка перейшла в праву частину,
як плюс три
Це є наслідок першої властивості.
Ним потрібно користуватись.
Також існує і друга властивість рівнянь.
Вона трохи схожа на першу.
Властивість каже:
що якщо обидві частини рівняння
помножити або поділити
на одне й те саме число,
але, увага, відмінне від
нуля, яке не дорівнює нулю,
то корінь рівняння,
знову ж таки, не зміниться.
Давайте продемонструю це на прикладі.
Нехай у нас є звичайне,
елементарне рівняння
2 помножити на х дорівнює 8
Дивимось на дошку.
Всі знають корінь -
це легко розв’язується.
Х буде дорівнювати одразу чотирьом.
Дивимось на дошку.
Зараз я помножу обидві
частини рівняння, наприклад, на 3.
Давайте запишемо, що в нас вийде.
Дивимось на дошку.
Ви бачите, я зараз обидві
частини рівняння помножив на 3.
Давайте запишемо результат. 2х
– це те саме, що 2 помножити на х.
Використовуючи сполучну властивість
множення, я можу просто 3 помножити на 2,
а потім помножити на х.
Дивимось на дошку.
Три помножити на два
буде шість помножити на х
Дорівнює 8 помножити на 3 буде 24
Для того, щоб зараз знайти
корінь даного рівняння,
потрібно добуток поділити
на відомий множник.
Тобто 24 роділити на 6 Дивимось на дошку.
Х буде дорівнювати чотири
Як бачите, корінь рівняння не змінився.
Отже, властивість працює.
Аналогічно можете
проробите те саме з діленням.
Ви можете дане рівняння:
2 помножити на х = 8
обидві частини поділити на 2.
І переконатися, що корінь не зміниться.
Давайте перейдемо до
застосування властивостей рівняння.
Отже, давайте перейдемо
до розв’язування рівнянь,
які розв’язуються за
допомогою цих властивостей.
Перейдемо до прикладів.
Увага на екран.
7х додати 32 дорівнює 12х додати 25
Давайте уважно подивимось на це рівняння.
У нас є ліва і права частинка.
В лівій частині у нас невідоме 7х,
в правій частині невідоме 12х.
Головним принципом
розв’язання таких рівнянь є те,
що всі невідомі доданки ви
повинні перенести в ліву частину,
а всі відомі доданки
перенести в праву частину,
використовуючи основну
властивість рівнянь.
Те що, переносячи доданок
з однієї частини в іншу,
ви повинні змінити його
знак на протилежний.
Давайте це проробимо.
Дивимось на дошку. 12х нам відповідно
треба перенести в ліву частину рівняння
Тобто перекинути через знак «дорівнює»
Плюс 32 – це відоме значення
Ми його повинні перекинути
в праву частину рівняння
Давайте запишемо результат.
7х в лівій частинці так і залишається.
Увага, з правої частинки 12х
перейде в ліву частинку, як минус 12х.
Чому?
Тому що, якщо перед
числом ніякого знаку не стоїть
- це означає, що перед ним
стоїть, так званий, віртуальний плюс.
Отже, плюс 12х перейде в
іншу сторону, як минус 12х.
Записуємо результат.
Увага на екран. Дорівнює:
плюс 25, або просто 25 в
правій частині так і залишилось
Плюс 32 з лівої частини
переходить в праву як мінус 32
Чудово. Давайте зведемо
подібні доданки в
кожній частині рівняння.
7х мінус 12х буде дорівнювати мінус 5х
Дивимось на дошку.
7 хлібців мінус 12 хлібців – мінус 5х
Буде дорівнювати 25 – 32 = мінус 7
Для того, щоб знайти
зараз корінь рівняння,
мені потрібно добуток
поділити на відомий множник.
Тобто на минус 5
х буде дорівнювати минус
7 розділити на мінус 5
Відповідь запишемо дробом.
Х дорівнює - УВАГА, мінус розділити на
мінус - результат буде додатнім.
Зверніть увагу на дошку. Сім п’ятих
Це неправильний дріб.
Можемо перевести його в мішане число.
Х дорівнюе - одна ціла дві п’ятих
Це і є корінь рівняння.
Ось таким чином розв’язується рівняння
за допомогою їх властивостей.
Перейдемо ще до одного приклада.
Отже, наступне рівняння.
Дивимось на дошку.
8х дорівнює минус 8 додати 12х
Аналогічно до першого рівняння,
ми повинні з’ясувати, що у
нас в лівій частині 8х невідоме,
а також невідоме є і
в правій частині +12х.
Відповідно, з правої частинки ми повинні
це +12х перености в ліву частинку,
змінивши його знак на протилежний.
Бачимо, що в лівій
частині 8х так і залишається
Ми його переписуємо
Плюс 12х з правої частини
переходить в ліву частину як мінус 12х
Дорівнює: мінус 8 ми не чіпаємо,
воно так і залишаеться в правій частині -8
Зводимо подібні доданки в лівій частині,
Дивимось на дошку.
8х - 12х це буде мінус 4х
Буде дорівнювати мінус 8
Знову ж таки, приклад
схожий на попередній.
Для того, щоб знайти х,
потрібно –8 розділити на –4.
Відповідь запишу одразу.
Подивіться на дошку.
Х буде дорівнбвати двум
Розв’язали, переходимо
до інших прикладів.
Наступний приклад виглядає так.
Дивимось на дошку.
- 1.74х + 7.92 = 1.08х
Давайте перейдемо до розв’язання.
Оцінимо нашу ситуацію.
В лівій частині в нас
невідоме мінус 1,74х,
також невідоме є і в
правій частині мінус 1,08х.
В лівій частині у нас є
і відомий доданок 7,92.
Ми повинні з вами перенести всі
невідомі доданки в ліву частину,
а відомі доданки в праву частину.
Тобто: -1.08х переходить в ліву частинку
Відповідно плюс 7,92
переходить в праву частинку
Давайте запишемо результат цього
Дивимось на дошку. Минус 1.74х
так в лівій частині і залишаеться
З правої частинки мінус
1,08х переходе як плюс 1,08х
З лівої частинки плюс 7.92
переходить в праву як мінус 7.92
Змінює знак свій на протилежний
В лівій частинці ми повинні з
вами звести подібні доданки.
Увага на дошку.
- 1.74х додати 1.08х
Буде мінус УВАГА - мінус
один плюс один – буде 0,
Минус 0.74 плюс 0.08 буде минус 0, 66х
Дорівнює минус 7.92
Нам з вами потрібно
розв’язати елементарне рівняння.
Для цього –7,92
повинні поділити на –0,66.
Розв’яжемо це елементарне рівняння.
Для того, щоб знайти невідоме х,
ми мінус 7,92 повинні
розділити на мінус 0,66.
Очевидно, що знак кореня
рівняння буде додатнім,
але давайте пригадаємо як
діляться десяткові дроби між собою.
Я пророблю це в стовпчик.
Увага на дошку.
Нагадаю, як це робиться.
Я повинен і в діленому, і в дільнику
паралельно перенести кому
праворуч на стільки знаків,
щоб дільник був натуральним числом.
Очевидно, що нам потрібно
перенести кому в дільнику на два знаки.
Очевидно тоді що і в першому діленому
ми повинні кому пенести на два знаки.
Отже, результат буде такий
самий, що і ділення числа 792
На чило 66 (не пишеться 0.66)
Давайте поділимо це в стовбчик
Увага на дошку.
Спочатку я бачу що в
79 вміщаеться 66 один раз
Відповідно пишу значення 66
Віднімаю – буде 13, і зношу двієчку
132 поділити на 66 -
ділиться націло - це буде 2
2 на 66 це 132
дорівнює нуль
Отже, результатом буде число 12.
Це і буде нашим коренем рівняння.
Х дорівнює 12
Перейдемо до більш складних рівнянь.
Наступне рівняння.
Дивимось на дошку.
6 помножити (х - 2) дорівнює 2х
Це рівняння трошки складніше,
тому що не одразу ми можемо перенести
з обох частин рівняння невідому - в іншу.
Для цього спочатку треба в
лівій частині розкрити дужки.
Яким чином?
За допомогою розподільної
властивості множення.
Нагадаю її.
Для того, щоб розкрити
дужки в даній задачі,
потрібно спочатку 6 помножити на х,
потім 6 помножити на 2
і між ними поставити знак мінус.
Отже результат буде такий
6х відняти (одразу перемножую
6 на 2) 12 дорівнює 2х
Увага на дошку. Далі все досить
легко, ми з вами переносимо 2х
в ліву частину, мінус 12
відповідно в праву частину
Записуємо результат.
6х УВАГА залишаеться в лівій частині
2х перейде з правої частини як мінус 2х
Дорівнює: мінус 12 в правій частині
буде як плюс 12, або просто 12
6х - 2х буде 4х
4х дорівнюватиме 12
Зараз я швидень ко запишу результат
Для того, щоб знайти х треба 12
розділити на 4, х (буде дорівнювати) 3.
Переходимо до наступного рівняння.
Наступне рівняння виглядає так.
Дивимось на дошку.
Для початку нам, знову ж таки потрібно
в лівій частині рівняння розкрити дужки.
Тут вони розкриваються
трошки інакшим способом.
Нагадаю, для того, щоб розкрити
дужки, перед якими стоїть просто знак «–»,
потрібно цей «–» і дужки
прибрати, а кожен знак в дужках,
тобто кожен доданок,
його знак, потрібно
змінити на протилежний.
Подивимось що у нас вийде
Одничку я так і залишаю
далі мінус і дужки я прибираю
в мене залишаеться 3х, я
повинен змінити його знак,
тобто буде мінус 3х
і відповідно плюс 1
потрібно змінити на мінус 1
дорівнюе 2х
Подивіться уважно. Що в нас вийшло?
1 відняти 1, буде 0. В правій
частині можна їх закреслити.
Це, так зване,
взаємознищення двох доданків.
Дивимось на дошку. Отже, один і мінус один
дорівнює нулю. Доданки взаємознищились.
В лівій частині в мене
залишаеться лише мінус 3х
З правої частини, УВАГА, 2х я переношу
В ліву частинку як мінус 2х
Дивимось на дошку.
Питання, а що ж
залишаеться в правій частині?
Ми все забрали з правої частини, всі
доданки, отже там нічого не залишаеться
тобто нуль
Зводимо подібні доданки в лівій частині
Дивимось на дошку.
- 3х -2х буде дорівнювати -5х
дорівнювати нулю
Для того, щоб знайти х потрібно
0 розділити на –5.
Відповідно, х буде
дорівнювати просто нулю.
Розв’язуючи цей приклад, в
мене виникло питання до вас:
а скажіть, будь ласка, який
буде корінь рівняння саме такого?
Подивіться на дошку.
Нуль помножити на х дорівнює нулю
Корінь цього рівняння буде довільне число.
Тому що яке б ви число
замість х не підставили зараз,
він буде коренем рівняння.
Нуль помножити на
довільне число - буде нуль.
В такому випадку пишуть х довільне число,
або рівняння має безліч розв’язків.
Або, якщо ще правильніше
написати, пишуть ось таким чином.
Увага на дошку.
Х належить R
Це буде означати, що х належить
множині всіх дійсних чисел.
Але більш детально цей
запис ви вивчите в 7 класі.
Наступний приклад буде в собі
мати комбіноване розкриття дужок.
Давайте поглянемо як.
Увага на дошку Мінус (3х + 1) буде
дорівнювати 3 помножити на (3 - х)
Ми повинні розкрити дужки і в
лівій частині, і в правій частині.
Давайте це зробимо
В лівій частині дужки розкриваються
за рахунок правила, що
перед дужками стоїть знак «–».
Отже, «–» і дужки будуть прибиратися,
а кожен доданок з дужок буде
змінювати свій знак на протилежний.
Отже результат буде такий.
3х стане мінус 3х, плюс 1 стане мінус 1
Дивимось на дошку.
Перейдемо до правої частини.
В правій частині у нас виконується
розподільна властивість множення.
Рішення дивимось на дошці.
Трійка множиться на 3, буде 9
І потім трійка множиться
на мінус х, буде мінус 3х
Далі пророблюемо стандартну процедуру
Ми переносимо всі невідомі доданки ліворуч
це мінус 3х справа
І всі відомі доданки праворуч,
це мінус 1 в лівій частині
Записуємо наш результат
Мінус 3х плюс 3х
Дорівнює 9 і УВАГА - мінус 1 іде як плюс 1
Що у нас виходить?
-3х +3х можна записати двома способами
Або нуль х (0х)
Або просто нуль, оскільки ці
доданки у вас взаемознищуються
Вони з однаковим коефіцієнтом
(трійка), і з різними знаками
або просто нуль х
Нуль помножити на х дорівнює 10
Цікаво, а результатом
розв’язку цього рівняння що є?
0 помножене на якесь
число повинно дорівнювати 10.
Такого числа, насправді, не існує. Чому?
Тому що, яке б число ми не
помножили на 0, все одно буде 0.
Воно ніколи не буде дорівнювати 10.
Або ж для того, щоб знайти
х, треба 10 поділити на 0.
Ви пам’ятаєте, що на 0 ділити не можна.
Отже, результатом цього
рівняння, або коренем цього рівняння
є така фраза: коренів немає.
Дивимось на дошку.
Пишуть - не має коренів
Або – розв’язків немає
Або – щоб взагалі правильно
писати – пишуть ось такий символ
Дивимось на дошку.
Він називаеться «порожня множина»
Це множина, яка не
містить жодного елемента
Але, знову ж таки, з цим символом
ви познайомитесь в старших класах
Перейдемо до найскладніших
прикладів на сьогодні.
Отже, найскладніший приклад за сьогодні
Дивимось на дошку.
2 помножити (х - 11) мінус 5 помножити
(5 - 2х) буде дорівнювати мінус 23
Як і в попередніх прикладах,
ми повинні спочатку
розкрити дужки в лівій частині.
В обох випадках (і в цьому
доданку, і в цьому доданку)
дужки розкриваються за рахунок
розподільної властивості множення.
Давайте це зробимо.
В першому моменті все
зрозуміло. 2 множиться на х, буде 2х
2 множиться на -11, буде -22
Давайте перейдемо до другого прикладу
Точніше - до других дужок.
В цьому прикладі досить часто
школярі допускають помилку.
В чому помилка?
– 5 вони множать на 5, і пишуть -25
Так, все правильно, вони праві
Потім множать 5 на –
2х, і в них виходить -10х.
УВАГА! Зараз я допустив помилку. Чому?
Тому що я повинен за
розподільною властивістю множення
-5 множити на 5, війде -25,
Але потім -5 множити на -2х
Увага на екран
– 5 помножене на – 2х, буде плюс 10х.
Не робіть тут помилку.
Дорівнює -23
Далі все просто. Невідомі
доданки переносимо ліворуч
Відомі доданки переносимо праворуч
Всі невідомі доданки (2х, і плюс
10х) в мене вже в лівій частині.
Залишилося - 22, і -25 перенести праворуч
Попередньо, насправді,
можна обчислити скільки це буде
-22 і -25 буде - 47
Давайте подивимось, що
в нас вийде в лівій частині
2х додати 10х буде 12х
Увага на дошку
Дорівнює: -23 в правій
частині так і залишається
-22-25=-47
Коли перейде в праву частинку,
змінить свій знак на протилежний
Тобто буде плюс 47
Давайте обчислимо, що в
нас війшло в правій частині
12х (ліва частина),
-23+47 буде дорівнювати 24
Легко знаходиться х
х буде дорівнювати 24
розділити на 12, або ж просто 2
Рівняння завершено.
Ми його розв’язали.
Отже, сьогодні ми з вами
познайомилися з властивостями рівнянь.
Нагадаю їх:
Обидві частини рівняння
можна помножити або поділити
на одне й те саме число,
яке відмінне від нуля.
Або до обох частин рівняння можна додати,
або відняти одне й те саме число.
Нулем воно може бути.
Наслідок з останньої властивості є такий:
З довільної частини рівняння
можна перекидувати доданки.
Я маю на увазі - переносити
доданки з однієї частини в іншу.
Але не забувайте, будь ласка,
змінювати їх знак на протилежний.
Таким чином розв’язується
велика кількість рівнянь.
До нових зустрічей,
де ми з вами розв’яжемо
більш складні рівняння.